all this pageantry shows at the world
how the peaceful transfer of power in
america remains a powerful symbol of
freedom
and renewal so we're going to start with
wijajang she's at the white house with
the new president's path forward
wija it was such a day what a night i'll
bet this president is not sleeping in
good morning to you
good morning to you gail president biden
urged americans to end what he called
an uncivil war and he spoke really
bluntly about all the problems wrapped
up in it
in his first act as president he held a
moment of silence to honor more than 400
000 people in the u.s who have died to
coven 19
but there were so many moments of joy
too as the celebrations
went throughout the night
as it has for more than 200 years
america once again displayed a peaceful
transition of power
an epic fireworks show capped off the
historic
inauguration we've learned again that
democracy is precious
because of you democracy has prevailed
newly inaugurated president joe biden
addressed the nation
last night from the lincoln memorial
there isn't anything we can't do
if we do it together
[Music]
the nighttime celebration brought
together musical performances
[Music]
tributes to frontline workers
and a taped appearance by three former
presidents the fact that the three of us
are standing here talking about a
peaceful transfer of power speaks to the
institutional integrity of our country
we will be available
in any ways that we can as citizens to
help you guide our country forward
mr biden becomes president as the nation
navigates several
crippling crises which he noted in his
inaugural address
we face an attack under democracy and on
truth
a raging virus growing inequity
the sting of systemic racism a climate
in crisis
america's role in the world the
president built his about
21-minute speech around what he sees as
the solution
unity my whole soul is in this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause just two weeks earlier
pro-trump rioters attacked the very spot
from which she spoke
a fact president biden tackled head on
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue and i promise
you i will fight as hard for those who
did not support me
as for those who dare joseph robinette
biden jr do solemnly swear
the president took the oath of office
with a 128-year-old
family bible that he has used many times
before
having served as a delaware senator for
36 years
and vice president for 8.
vice president kamala harris made
history as the first
female elected to the position and the
first black
and south asian woman too so help me god
so help me god
the theme of bridging divides ran
through the program
truly poet amanda gorman stunning the
crowd with her original work
for there was always lights if only
we're brave enough
to see it if only we're brave enough
to be it the traditional parade route
from the capitol to the white house was
only lined with police and service
members
but the bidens walked the last part of
it so the world could see them arriving
at their new home
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
and when president biden made his way to
the oval office a letter from
former president trump was waiting for
him on the resolute desk
president biden says he wants to keep
the contents private for now but
described it as
generous this morning he and vice
president kamala harris will participate
in a virtual prayer ceremony that will
be streamed
nationwide anthony a lot of people would
like to know what's in that letter ouija
thank you